it's the big moment from the debate Dana
was just telling us about can anybody on
the stage defeat Trump
candidates it's now obvious that if you
all stay in the race former president
Donald Trump wins the nomination
none of you have indicated that you're
dropping out so
which one of you on stage tonight should
be voted off the island
please use your marker to write your
choice on the notepad in front of you 15
seconds starting out of the people on
the stage who should be I'm absolutely
with all due respect I mean we're here
like we're happy to debate but I think
that that's disrespectful to my fellow
competitors I think I've been the only
one on this stage that's been clear
about this I vote Donald Trump off the
islands right now what did you think of
DeSantis there you know what I gave him
credit because santis didn't look around
do you remember the first debate he
looked around to see what other people
were doing before he raised his hand
with everyone I think it was about will
you support the candidate that the party
nominees
um I like that I like that he indicated
that you know I'm not going to play this
you know where you go and you go here's
the bottom line Trump is at 56. he's 42
points ahead of DeSantis you know what
Trump wins whether they're all in or out
Trump still wins and then you have Iowa
and that'll Shake loose a bunch of
people yeah it should
um but people should get this together
sooner if they really think that Donald
Trump is not the guy that should be
leading the Republican party there has
to be some coordination it's a numbers
game at this point
um and I thought it was interesting
timing that today there's the report out
about the draft young kin situation
there's going to be a
a retreat October 17th through 18th all
these donors who obviously are not
seeing anything that they that they like
like the Ken Griffins of the world who
runs Citadel and said I'm not giving to
anyone until I see someone that's worth
my time are going to be going and
hearing about the potential to do this
ballot access is going to be a problem
is you have the signatures in time Etc
but the fact that people with money and
we know that money controls elections
are looking at last night and saying you
know what we should do we should go find
another guy
it does not bode well for the anyone but
Trump
sounds like somebody else we know that
rhymes with Joe Biden
concept it's really bad it's worse I
mean at least Trump can you know connect
some sentences together we did the
coherence thing I know and you were
dishonest but that's okay no I wasn't
yes you were let's go back and roll the
tape okay I I still remember it go ahead
Greg yeah oh um yeah he's in the
driver's seat trumps in the driver's
seat there's no question I I think that
of the of the candidates there the the
people that have that could go up
against them have the most guts Nikki I
thought showed some guts Vivek I thought
Vivek had a really strong moment when he
was talking about Tran the trans
movement among kids and he offers a
really good
framing by by saying that it's a mental
disorder among children then you could
only deal with it non-invasively because
when you're dealing with a psychological
problem you you you deal with it with
therapy or time or observation but the
left views it as a physical problem so
you deal with it physically chop it off
so the fact is if you who would you what
would you rather how would you rather
look at this as a psychological issue or
a physical issue one has permanent
ramifications the other one allows you
to make decisions over time and I
thought that he introduced that idea
very perceptively yep he does have some
good ideas and he's very articulate he
is very articulate um
um okay uh with that in mind
um yeah but you you do look at the rest
of the field it's what 36 37 if you put
together all the percentages for
everybody who's not Trump I mean judge
you you do the math and I think that
that gets really tricky
um but you think about moving forward
this is what's really starting to scare
is people is not only the Glenn young
thing and I don't think he'll do it I
pressed him on that on Fox News Sunday
he got pressed today I think by John and
Sandra um I don't think he does it but
this third party thing is really
starting to freak people out in the
Democrat Party you heard James Carville
talking about it saying he thinks it
tilts things for Trump
um you know so Trump is all about
encouraging this no labels does it end
up being Mansion or somebody else I
think that that's the real worry now on
The Binding side of the ticket I just
add to the third party thing it really
depends who the third party is Carvel
didn't get it into if it's Joe manchin
maybe if it's RFK Jr
then Trump has more problems than the
Democrats but even if Cornell West
amounts and pulls like a percentage or
two I mean even pay his child support
wow
I have to look at that all right ahead
Democrats try to block Republicans from
laying out the damning New Evidence at
Biden's first impeachment inquiry
hearing hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else